[Music]
from remote learning for kids to zoom
calls for their parents the pandemic has
pushed technology into our lives like
few things before
that has many yearning for a simpler
time and for some that means a revival
of some old-time office gear
from our cbs affiliate wbz in boston
david wade reports
at first glance it is a graveyard keys
and ribbons space bars and knobs
a mound of machines
probably four or five hundred
with stories written and forgotten years
ago this is all i need
but tom furrier has fought to keep the
typewriter alive for decades at the end
of the very first day this voice in my
head said this is it that first day at
cambridge typewriter was 41 years ago
he's gone from young apprentice to owner
as the world went from typewriter to
tablet the business was decimated was
there a time where you thought
the business was just done i was weeks
away from telling my landlord that
that's it i'm
i'm cashing out and closing down
but over the past two decades
typewriters became vintage vintage
became cool and then the pandemic hit
my phone started ringing off the hook
when the lockdown began tom decided he
was going to start selling his
typewriters curbside so people would
literally window shop coming up to the
window pointing at the typewriter they
would want to try and then tom says they
would come outside to this bench to see
if that typewriter
was just their type we are the busiest
we've ever been in 41 years
in a time of doom
and zoom
customers tell tom they want something
simple i'm sick of my laptop i'm
throwing it away quick sell me a
typewriter
for real i didn't have any in-person
classes so i had more time at home
fifteen-year-old abigail gaffkin is an
aspiring writer she started her own
newsletter during the pandemic can i try
that one and she's one of tom's frequent
visitors i think the really cool thing
about the typewriters is you feel kind
of connected to the people who've used
it in the past and then of course the
clickety clacks everybody loves
computers crushed the typewriter a
pandemic has brought them back
and tom furrier is busier than ever
happily refusing to turn the page
my wife will find me with a
spring hook and a screwdriver in my hand
slumped over a typewriter one day and
that'll be it
for cbs saturday morning david wade
arlington massachusetts
the clickety clack of a typewriter is my
it's the memory of my grandmother
because she would write letters
every weekend it was unbelievable i'd be
waking up to it i remember using a
typewriter and using at least you know
an electric typewriter but still using a
typewriter and that sound there is a
ritual to it yeah it is so indeed
remember white out
yes
for those of you you gotta go back and
you have to yeah yeah i aged myself with